[Music]
hi
everyone welcome to the stanford mba
program panel focused on students and
alumni from africa
thank you all so much for joining my
name is saba khan i'm a member of the
stanford mba admissions office
all right i think we are waiting for a
couple of
uh additional alumni to join us but in
the meantime want to get started with
some introductions for those
uh panelists who are on the call now
um tayo do you want to kick us off just
a little bit about yourself
and would also love to hear about your
favorite
academic experience at stanford
sure i appreciate it um well thank you
very much everyone for
for joining on um and it's great to be
here again good to see you again saba
and
ron so my name is tayo vyosu and i am
the founder and group ceo of
paga a mobile payments company here in
nigeria
i'm class of 2005 at the gsb
um and even though that's been a while
it doesn't feel that way
um what was my favorite um
experience i would say the class that
really stands out to me
and i feel like i i use this every day
is
managing growing enterprises uh with
joel
peterson um and and it's because this
was a class where
every single session you had a
small case study um and
you came to class and you role played it
um and it wasn't a i think i will do x
no you actually acted it out and you
went back and forth with various team
member people on the
in the class and at the end of the class
you know for the last call at 15 minutes
or so you have the protagonist
of the case actually there um and who's
been watching this thing diligently and
uh and then right now chimes in about
what actually happened and what you got
what we did in class
i feel like uh my life as an
entrepreneur um is all about managing
growing enterprises
um and every day there's a new there's a
new challenge there's something
uh different that comes up that i have
to address so that's that's that has
stayed with me
quite a lot awesome thanks
ron would you like to go ahead
that's tough to follow um
my name is ron o'tamale i'm also class
of 2005
with tile i was actually a bit
apprehensive about
joining this because i was thinking to
myself how much can i add given that i'm
15 years removed seems like
seems like yesterday but it's really a
long time ago but then i saw tai on the
list who's a friend
and a fellow classmate i said i guess i
won't be the only old person here
um so uh i'm based in johannesburg
i run a private equity firm called
affirma capital
which is one year old we it was the
former private equity firm
under standard chartered bank and we
acquired it
a year ago the partners acquired the
business a year ago
my favorite class there were so many at
the gsb my favorite
academic experience was a class called
investment management
i think that was the or investing
and it was taught by professor mcdonald
and basically the class was people
called it a speaker session
although i didn't view it that way um
they just brought in people from
different walks in terms of investing
when you think about the investing world
you
you may think only private equity or
only vc
but i mean you bro they brought in
people from the vc world
uh the private equity world family
offices
anybody that invests money whatever that
looks like
and it was quite interesting to just see
people's approach
uh on how you do that and the most
amazing speaker we had in that class
was charlie munger who is uh well
at the time warren buffett's uh partner
in berkshire
and i think at the time when he came to
speak to us he was about 80 years old
but he was even in a wheelchair but to
sit here and see
this is one of the best investors in the
world sitting there speaking to our
class very casually
uh and how humble he was that was quite
quite amazing for me
awesome thanks zepho thanks so much for
joining
we're just doing quick introductions so
a little bit about yourself and
maybe where you're calling in from and
then your favorite academic experience
at stanford
and you're on mute
it's the zoom life these days yes it's
the it's the most common line i think
uh in meetings these days
um so my name is ziposika i'm calling in
from johannesburg i'm from south africa
and also currently based in south africa
so i'm glad to be part of the the
conversation today so
i'm the ceo of emz advisory so it's a
company i started a couple of years ago
after i left business school and you
know we help a lot
of organizations become effective become
more productive
looking at leadership change management
culture etc
and working across with different
multinationals that are
you know focusing on emerging markets
more particularly south african context
and across the board so i'm gsb
2014 it feels like long ago so
i'm so very very glad to be seeing some
older but familiar faces from the
stanford community
and um i think for me you know the thing
that um
stands out i think if i just look back
at my favorite
time and the thing that really stands
out for me is just i was really just
impressed with
um you know some of the professors i
mean
just wow just the not so much you know
yes of course there's the experience and
there's the expertise
but it's just the level of care and the
passion that they had and really helping
us
um figure out our journeys right and
really find out what our why
is what's how impact is going to be what
our parts are going to be and just
seeing that coming from the heart is
something that really really
stood out for me uh to this day and so
yeah so that's the that's the input from
my side
awesome thanks and josh is
joining us as a current student so
joshua feel free
introduce yourself and maybe your
favorite academic experience so far
hi everyone um i'm joshua
um it's an honor
following those who have gone before me
and it's nice meeting all of you very
happy to be able to join you today i'm
calling from my dorm room
in stanford california which you can see
is this
masterpiece behind me um
as to my favorite academic experience i
will confess that i was taking notes for
entire
runway listing their classes because
they just opened the class registration
portal and so i definitely will take
those classes now
i'd say that in my first year i would
lean more
technical i gained the most from the
optimization and simulation modeling
class
coming from a background where i was
thinking more disease
or opening bodies for a living
it was nice to be able to tell stories
with
numbers um and osm
concretized that for me so i think
it's a skill that i'm currently using in
my
internship and i think that it will save
me for many years to come
awesome thanks so much all right
i'm gonna actually stop sharing um
this background slide um it looks like
maybe we missed out on a couple of
panelists but um no worries
there um i'm gonna switch so everyone
can see the panelists
and i'm gonna start taking questions
from those of you who are
on the call and joining us today so
feel free to submit questions via the q
a chat you can also upvote questions
with a thumbs up
so actually the first question i can
answer which is
asking about the africa fellowship
program and is that something that will
be reinstated
so we actually did conclude that program
um last year and so we don't have plans
to reinstate that fellowship but
i really want to just emphasize how
generous
our need-based financial aid is so
part of the reason that we concluded the
program is that we actually revamped all
of our need-based financial aid so
on average um each student with the
highest need is receiving significantly
more financial aid than they
previously used to we kind of um redid
our algorithm there are also
alternative scholarship programs out
there including
at stanford um including the night
hennessey scholars program
so i would really just encourage
everyone who's considering stanford to
throw your hat in the ring
and once you get in everyone will have
access to financial aid funding
opportunities
um we've got another question here um
asking let's see
i was curious to know how students from
africa connected
in kind of an international program so
were there any kind of cultural
either barriers or challenges to
adapting to an american mba program and
this is a question coming from south
africa
just kind of talking about international
culture and
potentially any just challenges
coming from africa in particular
maybe two or three of you could chime in
on this one
i guess i can take that since i'm
freshest of the block
[Music]
so i think two days after i
landed on campus there was this event
where
someone well spoke to us or spoke to the
people gathered
and said there's a policy
that um everyone at stanford i think
abides to
or abides with which is assuming best
intentions
and i found that to
lead to let's call it an
open mind so to speak
which came in very handy when it came to
processing what i had considered the
change in circumstances or the changing
environment
um and i think that that is actually
very critical to
enjoying or making the best of the
experience
[Music]
outside your home zone or your
comfort zone the second is i think
stanford has been very intentional
about creating a community both amongst
international students and between
international and domestic students and
generally
even between faculty and staff and
um not just the intentionality but also
the um the
i think there's actually some science to
the way it is done
actually i think it's very effective and
so
i would say that at least amongst my
classmates
i i think that many people were able to
acclimate
quite easily and very effectively
nice
any other thoughts
all right um we have another question
coming in asking specifically about our
west coast location
in the u.s and um you know we all know
that
just geopolitically that's a big
distance from africa compared to maybe
some of our east coast schools or
european schools
and the question is how has gsb helped
you make an impact
in africa given the school is based on
the west coast
i would like to i would like to take
that first
please um i always say this
and i've been on the continent post gsb
for 12 years now
and my story is probably slightly
interesting because
um my parents were immigrants the us
from uganda
i moved to the us when i was very young
four years old my whole life
i grew up in the u.s and i've never
really been
back to africa since i was three or four
uh when going into the gsp my plan
or what i had in my mind i was always
interested in coming back to the
continent
and actually being an investor on the
continent
remember a place i had left when i was
four years old
um and my whole family's in the states
so
um the gsb actually was very
instrumental
in what i do now and actually me
relocating
and leaving my family which is actually
again under in california
and san diego to be specific to move to
johannesburg 12 years ago
and it was actually a lot of my
classmates a lot of my peers and and the
people
above us people like tyler uh
there's a gentleman named chenezy who
started a school
named pioneer academies which was my
roommate
at the gsb uh there's a gentleman named
fredronika who most of you guys will
know
started la these were all so my move
was actually a lot of it from my network
and the gsb networks first and foremost
secondly
having been on the continent for 12
years
i always say i always make the following
the gsb is smaller than some of the
other schools
but its impact on the continent is
actually phenomenal
what gsb alums are doing on the
continent
they punch well above their weight i
mean top
tier with finding paga myself with
finding founding
a former capital i just told you chinese
with
nova pioneer fred a music
zippo zone here there are so many of us
i mean there are so few that's been
having
huge impact on the continent so i would
not shy away
from saying i'll rather be on the east
coast of the country or the west coast
of the country
and then finally in terms of our
location
and the beauty of the of where stanford
is
i think you'll be doing yourself a
disservice not going there and
maybe i'm speaking out of uh as a
california person
but uh it's an amazing place
yeah i mean totally after what
ron just said and there's a lot behind
you know
that you can even unpack on this right
when when we were in school
i remember calling you know looking at
the alumni database
and there was really one or two alums
in nigeria um in fact and one of them i
just called him
out of the blue um and you know
and and got engaged but now here in
lagos and nigeria we have at least
15 um gs beers um and he told me
something
you know the alumni was was there then
told me something which is so true today
is that every one
every alum of any business school who's
in
on the african continent knows stanford
business school
respects the degree probably applied
um you know maybe they didn't get in or
something right right just
keep it clear like stanford has one of
the lowest admission rates
um and you know open doors for you
right so they treat you just like
they're
you're you went to their school right um
so
you get access regardless people know
the brand
people there's access there for me
stanford has been instrumental to my
business
i have on on our cap table
13 gsb alumni from
five different classes um on our cap
table
uh these are investors in my business
people i didn't go to school with
um but because of the tight knee knit of
that network
uh you know have all suggested in my
business and so
i've seen significant value uh from the
gsb
uh and and i think across all schools i
would argue that
the gsb has now you know invested
probably
you know as much as any other school in
terms of
its focus on africa um and its desire to
not only recruit directly from here
um but would actually be present right
uh with what's going on in ghana with
seed in kenya as well
uh with seed and helping entrepreneurs
who didn't even go to stanford business
school
as well with their businesses um and and
having a lot of impact
across the continent overall so i would
not worry about the distance
it is a long trip um i was supposed to
be
actually ron and i were supposed to be
in in san francisco
around now and you know it's a long trip
but aside from that
it's uh it's well worth it awesome
thanks we have a related question
actually from a couple of different
people about
why stanford which i think is kind of
similar
but maybe zippo and josh you could chime
in on that one specifically especially
if there were any points to consider
from an african perspective
um yeah even generally kind of why
stanford versus other schools
yeah yeah absolutely i could go ahead on
that one just to to get us started
the question is why is stanford and why
not stanford
um i think you know um ron was already
mentioning i mean
it's phenomenally beautiful by the way
the weather is great
which makes a really big difference
especially some of us coming from the
warmer side of the world
um the winter's there actually yeah
they pretty much if not the same if not
warmer than what we feel in south africa
so it's a beautiful place it's really
great it's really good energy i used to
say to people there's the
you know all the serious house about
california particularly the good ones
they're all true right it's just people
are really
free it's a place of opportunity there's
literally no judgment you can be whoever
you want
so i really like that i think the second
reason for me is that
you were talking about how long the trip
is it is actually far you actually take
two really really long flights
and for me um it's such an opportunity
right i mean leaving a place like that i
mean some of my closest friends right
just because the class is so small it's
also so intimate and you almost get to
know everyone by name
by the time we get to the end of the
program so some of my closest friends
um literally people i talk to regularly
i mean they're based in the us they're
braced in brazil you know they based in
other parts of africa
they faced in europe they based in china
i mean i was literally dancing at a
wedding in in january in
india because it was of a close friend
and you know 20 of us also from
different countries were sort of on the
program
for me that's something that is really
really hard to to get for
for example in general um etc and i
think one of the things that's that's
sort of nice about stanford is just
access to such a
a community of people and really getting
to know them well at an intimate level i
mean some of them i even know their
families their families visit me
and it's as if it's like home and and
vice versa and
i think the other thing that for me made
stanford really really stand out
particularly you know that the essay you
know
that's part of the application you know
what matters to you and why i mean
it wasn't just something that was on
paper but it's something that i felt
like i really lived for me the
experience really challenged me
to be you know what is the best leader
that i can become what's the best
version of me that i can become
and i really felt like i left having
found what
my what is my why and what's the impact
i can have in the world
not defined by anyone else not painted
by anyone else it was not influenced by
any stereotype about
you know what a leader is supposed to be
you know someone like me i've always
wanted
i've been an entrepreneur since i was
young right but i you know i spent
years in corporates working in different
countries and i could not really see how
i could make it happen
and then when i was at stanford i mean
we had you know entrepreneurs
business owners all these people from
you know some really young ones really
recent all the guys
the chillblazers today and you have also
some old school guys
and you see all these waves of
individuals coming to tell you their own
real life stories
and i saw myself you know i saw myself
that there's actually different ways of
becoming
whatever you want to become you know
whether it's an entrepreneur or not
um i just that for me is the main thing
that stood out and it still stands out
today so as my business you can imagine
with pandemic
you know we've all had to reform we've
had to change how we do things
i mean my biggest advisors are actually
my classmates from business school i was
just talking to one before this call
she was in the morning in the u.s it was
evening for me and you know she was
actually giving me
some guidance because she's worked with
a lot of leaders running businesses in
emerging markets
as an example and i wouldn't have an
opportunity like that
um if if i hadn't had a chance to to to
go to stanford
and et cetera et cetera and i i interact
with them for different things
and even the other one i mean i see a
lot of businesses
um from an investment perspective angel
stage
and you know a lot of my investment one
of them was a
roommate in you know in business school
he's starting an airline in nigeria
you know another one is in nigeria also
starting doing something in fintech
and then of course the education example
that it was already mentioned that's
growing across the continent it's also
another stand for the alumni
so i just feel like for me those are
opportunities that i honestly would not
have had if i
if i didn't have access to that to that
network
awesome josh you're on mute
yes
so i'll go next i echo a lot of what um
zifo just said um and specifically for
me
who was um in healthcare and academia
before i began to
look for a way to scale
solutions which is why i decided that i
needed a working knowledge of finance
which is why
i decided i needed an mba i
decided that the best school for me
would be somewhere where
it was okay to try and fail
um because i obviously was going to be
pivoting careers but not just that i was
going to be
trying out what i'd consider
competencies and skills that are maybe
sometimes not transferable
or directly transferable i was going to
be trying them in
new sectors i wasn't even sure what that
sector was
and as i read up on the profiles of all
these schools it seems like
stanford was a place where previous
failures were even worshipped
not just accepted it was like as long as
you learn from it it's a wonderful
um experience so that actually
solidified
um stanford for me secondly
i believe in something a concept one of
my mentors
taught me a few years ago something
called intrapreneurship
which is basically applying
entrepreneurship mentality
to structured um engagements and
organizations and the more i read up on
the profiles of people who
um you know i don't exploit post
stanford especially in africa the more i
saw a lot of those concepts you know
expressed in what it is that they did
and the way they went about
problems and i decided well i want to be
like those people and so
um there was that i'd see also
the another um major reason well other
than
the fact that stanford is known for
multidisciplinary learning which has
always attracted me was
immediately after my interview and i
spoke
to my interviewer i think that is the
nicest interview i've ever had in my
life it was literally like licking ice
cream
i was like any school that had this guy
i'm definitely going to that school
and i i genuinely think most most alumni
from stanford are
actually very warm very nice very
helpful people who
are always trying to be the teapot in
your life you know just paul
and point to you so that's why stanford
yeah can i can i build on one way you
just said there are two points i'll make
one uh just on that last point that
joshua just made
you know the fact that the business
school
has a non-grade disclosure policy
really enables you to you know
to be okay with failure right it's about
learning
for the sake of for really learning
right um
and what it what it does is it takes
away the competition amongst ourselves
right you literally before any exam you
have people who are really good at the
topic
um you know teaching the others right
and getting you ready for the same exam
that you're taking
and you're graded on curves right and it
still doesn't matter right like
you still do that um you come in
to um you know you come out of an
interview
and or you're about to go into an
interview and people actually tell you
oh this is the tough questions that were
asked right because it's about let the
best person
get it but about being collegial and
helpful so then the second thing i would
say
is look at any business school any of
the top business schools i think you get
a fantastic education
but i think what is really different
about stanford is
the approach to leadership and the
approach to the
pedagogy right so you know leadership is
really around
you know you leaders knowing yourself so
there's a lot of
coursework structured around you getting
to know yourself as a human being as a
person
and if you become a better person you're
a better leader
and then there's also a lot about you
know experiential learning
which i think is very different right so
really putting yourself into the
situation rather than
just book learning right i think those
are two things that are very different
about stanford
you know compared to other schools
yeah awesome great points um i hear that
over and over again from alums all over
the world for sure
um aisha it looks like you were able to
join
i'm going to ask you to unmute if you
feel
i'm ready to do a quick introduction
we've asked each of the panelists just
to share
a minute or two about your background
and then we also asked everyone to share
a little bit about your favorite
academic experience and i will also go
back to sharing
screen to show you um just kind of our
panelists backgrounds
while you introduce yourself okay
um hi everyone sorry i'm late i'm
actually sitting in the car but um
it's so good i managed to make it in the
end um
so um i guess i was class of 2017
um so my background um
studied in the uk i'm a stanford
undergrad
so stanford for life so i'm
extremely biased um
but um so i'm currently in nigeria i
recently
founded a startup which is a dairy
company working with smallholder farmers
um here in abuja and
um it's been quite the journey
and um i guess some of the other
question was what was my best academic
experience yes um so mg
mg is a class that um that's managing
growing enterprises that's a class that
i
keep coming back to over and over again
it's incredible how much my notes
and um some of the kind of um
checklists and cheat lists and things
like that that we got from so i took
mge with david dodson and
it was by far one of my best classes at
gsb
um and really it's it it served as a
guide
as um i've um started a company
as i'm building a team as i'm thinking
about
you know forming a board and just making
really difficult decisions
it's just been incredible just being
able to refer to those
notes and um really being able to kind
of now see
some of those um cases that we went
through um
and go through those um experiences
and being able to take away those
discussions and remember
some of the things we talked about so um
yeah i'm still amazed at how much i
thought
awesome all right it looks like we've
got some slight tech difficulties
oh there you go you're back sorry you
froze for one second but i think we
heard your um
mge answer which is great
all right um i'm gonna go back to taking
some
questions from those of you who are on
um so
we have one question that was around
um timing and how you knew that it was
the right time for you in your mba
the specific question was would you have
done it
earlier or later in your career but
maybe
like two or three of you could just time
it chime in on how you thought about
timing
i again feel like that question is best
suited to me
being fresh off the block so
um i am one of the more experienced
students at stanford um
so i guess having had work experience
and maybe previous post-graduate
education so it was
a bit of a dilemma
for me um deciding whether
that bought the nba boats had sailed
because i think i began to see the need
for an
mba in my life at least three or four
years ago
um i had maybe toyed with the idea
earlier
um when looking at postgraduate
education but i thought it was far
off few um however
i decided it was
uh let me rephrase that i decided that
as long as you are still thinking about
it it is the right time and once
you once it's not a recurring thought in
your mind and stuff like that then
maybe it is probably of lower value to
you and so the fact that it kept coming
and um will at least alter my
consciousness
um i thought um even if
it seemed of course now if you go on all
of those
websites and all of those blogs they'll
tell you oh once you're past a
particular age once you've passed a
particular level of experience you can't
get into an
mba you might as well just go and do
this and
i'm cool but i decided to try and well i
guess i'm here now so
i guess to those who are thinking about
is it the right time i probably can't
speak to those who maybe are thinking oh
i
don't have enough work experience i'll
let someone who may be
applied much earlier in their career
speak to that but for those who are
thinking of
applying as experienced in quote
um students i'd say that this time is
the right time
apply now
no that's great i guess i'll come in
next
um i applied after
two and a half years of work experience
so
out of undergrad two and a half years of
work experience and then i applied so
when i got to the gsp
i had three years of work experience um
for me
although i wasn't quote-unquote
switching industries uh
i was already in finance i was
i was trying to [ __ ] i had this itching
bug in me
of doing investing and doing it on the
continent
i always had this that something i
wanted to do
however i also needed to to learn more
about myself
and i think one of the panelists has
said this and i think going to the gsb
allowed me
one to take that time to take the two
years
i was i think i was on the younger side
of my classmates
not the youngest by far they're much
much younger
there was some that came straight out of
undergrad but it also
allowed me that two years to interact
with your classmates
and especially the the classmates from
the continent
or have lived on the continent to really
think about the plan that i had in mind
and so again i came out at a much
younger part of it
but it was to me a way to get away for
two years
really test the theory i had in my mind
and also get to speak to people that
were more experienced and specifically
in the industry i was trying to get it
which is the private equity side of
things and also to
engage uh with my classmates both the
people in my class
the people in the class above me and
then
the people in the class below me uh in
doing that
so it was some way of a career switch
per se
in terms of geography but not not
necessarily in terms of
what i do day to day
right um we do have
a lot of questions well first let me
just add to that because there is
another really specific question that
someone's asking
that's gotten a few other votes too and
it's about having
more advanced career trajectories so
um there's someone asking like hey i
have 13 years of industry experience
is this too late or disqualifying
and it's absolutely not so i think josh
kind of spoke to this
already but i think you know was
probably close to a decade maybe more
since
undergrad um when he joined the gsp
and uh typically the range of students
is everywhere from like ron said some
people are at
zero coming straight out of college and
others you know almost every single
class has people with more than 10
12 15 years of work experience so it is
a really diverse class
the middle 50 of the class typically has
four to six years but
that still means you know a quarter of
the class has more than six years of
experience so i just wanted to address
that person specifically since it seemed
like there were some other folks that
had
related questions about that
so one of the most popular questions
right now in the q a
is actually about the application
process so
as an admissions officer i always like
to quarterback these questions
first um with a little public service
announcement
so um one i would say there are actually
lots of ways to get to know more about
the application process and admissions
criteria and what we're looking for
so feel free to sign up if you take a
look at our events page
we have information sessions happening
weekly that speak directly
to that but um the specific question
that amed is asking is what's one thing
that you wish you knew during the
application process
that you know now and in hindsight wish
you had known at the time you had
applied
so um i don't know if that specifically
applies to application advice
necessarily it could be something you
learned about stanford
but just using hindsight is there
anything you would have
liked to have known about at the time
you applied
well i can give it a start on that one
it's a very difficult question so it's
clearly come from from someone who's
highly intelligent on the other side but
because if i look back i think for me if
i think of the biggest wake-up call
actually
was i actually was just surprised about
how much growth
i achieved from the application process
itself because it
really really forces you to introspect
i'm very grateful for the people who
i spoke to and asked for help and all
they said to me
is you know make sure it's you you know
invest time in
you make sure that this is the best
reflection of you
and that for me was one of the biggest
uh benefits because all the months i
spent on it
was probably one of the biggest growth
periods of my life
so now what i say to people is i say you
know what actually just
focus on the application as much as you
can because the growth alone
is absolutely priceless so if i could go
back and change one thing
i would have actually spent more time i
would have actually spent more into
introspection
because in hindsight it was literally
one of the biggest growth
moments in my life and yes i grew a lot
in the mba itself
but before the mba that was literally
probably the biggest growth moment
and it really forced me to really
reflect on what's really important in
life
so that by the time i got to stanford i
was then able to actually focus my
energies on those things
and really grow and develop and ask for
help on all that stuff and i think
as much as it's not tips per se i would
rather just say you know your
application
is yours right so this is your
opportunity you know to
to make it what you
what you believe you want it to be so i
yeah that's the
main reflection that comes for me
yeah i would i would echo that i think
my biggest surprise after school was how
much i learned about myself
i didn't expect that to be what i got
out of the business
um amongst other things and um
you know and i think there's also a
question about as an african you
you know along the same lines your
application how do you sort of position
yourself
um really the stanford application is
probably one of the toughest ones
um but the best way to approach it is
just
say they are writing this for yourself
and not for stanford and just be
brutally honest with what matters for
you
um you know and just lay it out there
and
you know and i think that the folks
reading the applications can tell when
you're trying to
fit in some sort of a mold rather than
just be yourself
yeah i definitely echo that too
yeah i can just chime in here and say
that across both the applications
process
and maybe my first few weeks here what
surprised me the most was how
unique you are but how common your
uniqueness
is so simultaneously
you are your only copy
but when you meet other very exceptional
people
you then realize you're challenged
to be maybe do better but also um
be a little bit less
i i'm looking for the perfect synonym
for proud
about your previous achievements but i'd
say
a little bit more inflective about all
of the other
um influences that helped you
on your route or your route to our path
towards um success so um
i'd say it's still surprising to me
because i'm still getting to
meet a lot of my classmates and when i
hear some of their stories
i am sometimes even moved to tears
that's awesome thank you for sharing
that
um we have a couple more questions this
one was specifically for tayo but i
think given how many of you
are now entrepreneurs i think feel free
to weigh in
um the question was did you work on paga
while at the gsv
and but i think we can also just address
more broadly
what is it like to start something while
in school
and what stanford resources were most
useful to you
um and i will just um insert a little
bit here that you know the gsb
is a full-time two-year program so we
want our students to be
fully invested in being students but
obviously given
you know we're in the heart of the
valley and embryonic to entrepreneurship
and that's a huge part of what students
are involved with
yeah i know very much um no i did not
start paga while i was in school
actually i started probably about four
years
later um but i actually tell people
that if i were to go back one thing i
wish i did
was either work on an idea while i was
in school
or whether it was my idea or somebody
else's idea it didn't matter
and it didn't even matter whether i even
go that after school
but just working on it while i was in
school because
it gave you because i think it would
have given me and i saw some of my
classmates doing it it would have given
me an opportunity
to um you know really
connect with other people in the
ecosystem at stanford
um outside of the business school it
would have given opportunity
to connect with people at the deep
design school
at you know some of the venture capital
community etc
so i would have i would have taken that
opportunity it is very hard
to run a business while you're in school
one of our classmates
uh did it successfully um his company
uh okay cupid uh you know was on the
east coast of the us
and he was up at 5am every day in on
calls
and then get ready for class and we had
it's a lot of diligence to really
really do that um so i would
just like it's tough to do it
yeah anyone else
want to chime in there's a related
question about startup garage i'm not
sure if anyone took that course
all right now where are you i could
i should go ahead um so i could chime in
um so i think i'm a bit different to i
guess most people that were in my class
um but i went into the gsb knowing
exactly
what i wanted to do afterwards um
so my experience felt like it was very
targeted and tailored towards kind of
helping me get there
so i knew i wanted to do something in
the dairy sector but i didn't really
know exactly what that would look like
so i kind of used my classes to explore
different models
to explore different ideas um
and just going thinking about um just
answering the question around startup
garage
i decided not to do startup garage
because
i felt that it wasn't suited for
ideas that were based far away
so a lot of startup garage requires you
to do a lot of
user interviews prototype testing
and if your idea is requiring operations
and deployment
in an african country it's kind of hard
with the time difference and everything
else to be able to do all of those
things effectively
so i didn't think that i would be able
to kind of have as rich an experience
doing starter garage and it probably
would get a bit frustrating not being
able to kind of
hit some of those milestones that were
acquired from the class
um but what i did do is i spent a lot of
time with the center for social
innovation
um being able to engage with um
so they were able to connect me with um
other entrepreneurs um on the continent
um that are working
on similar ideas um and that really
helped to be able to have
some of that experience but getting them
connected and having the csi team
um working with me through my ideas
um it was different but i think what i
would say is that
um you just curate your own experience
you know what you need you know what
you're looking for the resources are
there at the gsb
um so i think keeping an open mind
and knowing that sometimes you might
have to dig a little deeper
to figure out where you're going to get
that support
um or how you can kind of combine
different classes or opportunities to be
able to get that same
experience that you would get so i think
i was able to effectively do it without
necessarily taking startup garage but
being able to combine different classes
to be able to give me
some of those um experiences and
opportunities to
test things yeah
yeah if i can also add my perspective
and i actually echo a lot of what also
has been said i think
the big impact for me is that because i
started my business i think it was
within two years of actually finishing
the mba
so the difference for me was that it
actually accelerated just how soon i was
i felt ready to actually start my own
business and i haven't looked back ever
since we have anything we've been
growing
i've grown the team over time and also
the client base so for me i think that
the difference is i always knew that i
wanted to have my own business
one day but um i didn't think that it
would happen
anytime in the next near future and
literally after the stanford experience
i mean it was quick i mean i was in my
20s but i was like why not
and you know it gave me the confidence i
mean we work with you know executives
and ceos
helping them with their business
problems but the more the story is that
i don't think i would have had that
confidence
that you know i or we could deliver that
difference but it gave me that
confidence
and i think also um what aisha was
saying to say startup garage is one
examples
but there's really different ways that
you actually get to experience
right um you know what it means to be
involved in the business
or or to be part of a startup etc or
also to be part of it even a developing
business that's already there
and that there's so many different
courses that you can then pick which
angle you want to come from for example
and then learn from that perspective and
really really lean from there
i think the other thing that's important
is that there's just so many
opportunities at stanford there's so
many different things that you can do
with your time
so it's really really important to get
to a point where you learn to
prioritize when you get there because
you can't do everything
you know someone like me for example i
already had a business undergrad
so i knew that the thing that i wasn't
going to be focusing on too much
is the academic side of the business
content but i loved
the the other content particularly
around leadership it's something that's
close to my heart
and you know had a chance to do classes
um we call it across the street i
believe
and at the broader business school you
know because i'm actually quite very
very creative i mean i'm a fan of the
arts
um and stuff a lot of me know me from
the public speaking and stuff the talks
that i've given
but uh one of the things i did at
business school because i was able to
do classes across the street is i did
vocals you know i did a vocals class at
the mystic music school
i did an advanced movements class at the
acting school
i did a meditation and mindfulness class
at the school of medicine
uh things that normally i wouldn't have
time for if i ended up spending my time
saying i want to just focus on you know
start up this and start up that etc
so i think it's that to say there's so
much to do and also your classmates are
so amazing
that you actually want to spend a lot of
time with them and that's for me is
where i spend a lot of time really just
getting to know them
connecting with them and today it's
people that i feel like i can call
family and that wouldn't have happened
if i didn't make sure that i
make time available to be able to do
that
awesome thank you so
um we have about five minutes left so i
think this is going to be the last
question and i think that's a really
good one to end on muhammadu is asking
this great question
um to discuss a little bit further on
how stanford prepared you to tackle
challenges and opportunities in
africa so specifically can you give any
examples of classes or experience that
equipped you in navigating
african markets or the geopolitical
landscape
so just kind of any sort of specifics
around your stanford experience and how
it applied to your careers in africa now
i got one but i don't know others want
to go first
run it sounds like you want to go you
want to go first i think we should go
by the most recent to backwards
i've been living it for 11 years you go
first
josh are you free to kick it off josh if
you have a
answer um for something africa specific
and then we'll go backwards
so i do intend to return to the
continent
um in the not too distant future i am
very hurting by the experiences of those
that have made the move very
successfully um i i think the exact
um question please um help me sava
is um what exactly about the stanford
experience
makes that move successful right
yeah the specific question was
could you discuss further on how
stanford prepared you to tackle
challenges and opportunities in africa
ah that's perfect so
um ah where do i begin
um so tyler spoke earlier about the
pedagogy
and i think it's a problem
solving um
focused pedagogy and it's
it it combines the best of all worlds
both
experiential as well as um
well let's call it socratic or if you if
you
want a lot more um
pedagogy learning the issue is
that because the stanford
experience is structured into to the
first year which
gives you the general management base
and then the second year which
allows you to basically tailor your
experience um
you find out that you are
able to solve problems that maybe need
you to be more entrepreneurial and
creative in approach
but also sometimes more structured
and um a lot more bureaucratic
or um sequential in
your approach so i think that the fact
that there's this diversity of classes
that employs many different pedagogic
methods
and highlights each and
shall we say strengths and weaknesses of
many different approaches to doing
things
makes you a better problem solver
even if sometimes you don't even know
that it is happening
to you secondly because there's so much
intentionality
about um creating a community
and shall we say harnessing the strength
of your classmate
when you listen to a lot of the problems
they have tackled
both professionally and personally you
begin to realize that there's nothing
new under the sun
basically the biggest issue
would then be how to adapt your
learnings
because um for context it's strategy for
launch
one you can't use a one size fits all
what is it called solution everywhere
you go you then begin to think how
you're going to adapt to the solutions
they tried and failed or succeeded that
at whatever problems you are
um trying to solve um
more specifically i've noticed for
example as co-president of the africa
business club that we've had
a lot of people reaching out and saying
oh we don't know if
many of your classmates are interested
in maybe doing a small project
um helping a small and a small
organization here think through or walk
through a
problem now we have not started anything
along those lines but i can see how that
exposes you to problems on the continent
um even while as a student here where
you are be
where you are flexing those muscles that
you are beginning to develop in all of
the leadership and all of the strategy
and
all of the technical classes here and
lastly the amazing network that you have
access to both with
students who encompass with you and
alumni who are always welcoming
um to help you i think that is a
a vast resource that if you throw at any
problem even africa size problems
eventually you're going to be able to
withdraw them though
thanks i think just uh um
just to bring you back a bit on what
josh said around like
the problem-solving mindset i think one
of the things that stanford does
is kind of make you
embrace trying things out irrespective
of whether you're fit
you're going to fail or not right so
it's the mindset of um
going for it um but not necessarily
waiting till everything's perfectly
aligned before you go for it
and um not necessarily shooting for
success but shooting for that experience
of learning
um and trying something out and learning
from it and then iterating afterwards
i think that in the african context
there are so many so many challenges
um that you'll end up facing um
and as much as you think you know what
those are um
you keep getting curveballs thrown at
you and i think what stanford has done
is
helped at least for me embrace um
the fact that that is just part of the
journey and um
and i'm able to also be
introspective and not necessarily see it
as my individual failure but just
this is just what happens and it's the
question of what do you do afterwards
right um it's
going to happen so it's more about what
what what are the next steps you take
to think about the problem and think
about creative solutions
to um solve it
yeah um if i can answer that i think
from my perspective
it's um it really just pushed me to
think um you know
and actually aspire to solve things in a
way that's a little bit more global i
think one of also one of the challenges
of being in the in the african continent
is that sometimes you know you you you
you think you've created the best
solution and it's just best
right now it's best maybe in this town
or in the city or maybe even in your
country
and right now i mean even the lens at
which i look at my business now anything
we do my lens is global like
we aiming to be the best in the world at
what we do and i wouldn't have that lens
if i wasn't in an environment like
stanford where it basically said look
you can be at the best whatever you want
to be
in a global space so it also opened up a
little bit in my mind in terms of
possibilities
and what can be done from from it from
an african context because sometimes we
limit ourselves saying
but there's this this issue um i learned
to drop a lot of excuses and i just say
you know what
actually i guess it's possible i think
the other thing that it really helped me
with is actually just working on these
blind spots i mean we have these blind
spots
um if you think of the history right of
the oppression and all that complicated
history as a continent in general
i mean particularly coming out of south
africa and when i was at stanford it was
probably one of the first times in my
life that i actually got to really see
who i am and what's my identity beyond
some of the labels that
you know are so strongly put by society
on us in terms of what you can achieve
as you know call it a person of color or
as a woman or as an african it doesn't
matter
and all these limiting beliefs i mean
once you actually eradicate the impact
of
those blind spots it's really amazing
what your potential can truly become
and then the last thing for me was this
attitude of
actually believing that you can solve
the problem it doesn't matter how big
the problem is
um you know we also have this mindset of
warning there's a lot of things that we
can actually change and really make a
big difference on
and i see a lot of people um also
african-born talent
um sort of feeling defeated and they say
no i'm not gonna do this it's too
it's too late you know the politicians
are not doing enough and i think it
really shifted my mindset to say
but yes we can fix it and why don't you
try and fix it even if it's in your own
little way
if it's your own big way and it's not a
coincidence that if you look at some of
the businesses that stanford alumni
have actually started across the
continent and also across different
industries
it's phenomenal impact and at the end of
the day
i can see that seed within them myself
included where it just says you know
what
i think i can do it and let me go try
and if i feel who cares
but if it works the impact is phenomenal
um and that's something for me that
stood out
when i look at the coming from the from
the african continent
i'll go next taiyo if you don't mind
um so a class that really
has really helped me in my 12 years
working on
across the continent was a class we took
called managing with power
and this was basically a class about
influence
influence in organizations and politics
and it's all about i mean a key part
about africa is
implementation as we all know it you may
have the best idea
how do you get it done and some of that
implementation hits hurdles which are
either politically driven
or so how do you look at a situation
and basically kind of like a chess match
look at the whole board and try to
figure out the strategies what are
what are the different touch points what
are who are the different stakeholders
what what are their interests
how do you approach this party and that
party to get something unlocked
a lot of africa the complexity of our
continent
uh for example if you compare with asia
as an example and we do a lot of
business in asia
it's just getting through
um some just roadblocks knocking things
down
and getting things done and and and that
class was
very very good at that and really making
you to think strategically
on how to get things done and we we
being investors on the continent i've
seen this in many
many many ways one of our biggest one of
our our first investment that we've ever
made on the continent
was a was an investment in mt in nigeria
which most of you guys may know
uh we made an investment in 2008.
obviously amazing company largest mobile
phone provider
on the continent uh mtn but
nigeria being the best part of mta and
over the years i was still invested in
the company
we got helped by a five billion dollar
fine by the government of nigeria
we then got hit with a two billion
dollar fine for taxes
so just trying to figure out how do you
get this company
to get through these issues and who are
the different people we could use what
is
the real laying out what is happening
and this is just not unique
to mtn for example there are many other
private equity
firms of run companies on the continent
where this is the case and it's really
understanding who the stakeholders are
uh who the players are and how do we get
things
done obviously in an ethical way
but how do you find ways to get things
done and
i think that that class was really
instrumental in that
yeah i'll just pick you back on that and
say another class
that i um that i found i've found really
helpful
along similar lines a strategy beyond
markets
um and and it really helps you think
about the non-market
things that ron was talking about um and
it's actually been fun to go back and
teach
or let you know that class as well now
haven't experienced
it for a while but just sort of how do
you think about the regulators how do
you think about different
um non you know um market driven
um actors in your business but one thing
i will also say
you know fundamentally i've been also
really i guess not surprised but just
you know really want to draw that
business is business almost everywhere
like most part you know doing business
in the us
the things you will face as the
entrepreneur different scales
of like things and maybe different key
points
but you would find you're going to face
the same sort of struggles in
africa somewhere else and then there's
some unique things of course
you know but right now i'm in a pure
group of uh
some entrepreneurs from you know we're
in four continents
and um and we and and when we meet and
talk it's
you know we're facing the same same sets
of things
how do i you know issues my border and
my board my investors
my team you know like these are all
things about business and that's why
i would actually say that you know you
would learn
again from any of the top schools you're
going to get a great education
i think then it's about thinking about
where do i fit in
um and where am i going to get all the
other things that the help right and i
think
the tight-knit nature of of the gsb
because it's a small class
really uh stands out right this is uh a
family for life uh
just the same way as if i was saying she
was talking to another classmate in the
u.s today i've been on chat all day with
a classmate in hong kong
who you know um came to nigeria last
year
invested in my business uh and you know
and and
we're seeing more and more interest from
non-africans
on the african continent last december
130 gsb students
landed in lagos it was just like
amazing to see it right from all over
the world um
and so there's a lot of interest on
students as well
to the future of this continent so i
think i think that bodes well for for
for the business school down the line
for those of you in school now so joshua
really i'm really envious of you
actually
awesome well thank you all so much for
helping bring the gsb to life i'm so
appreciative i feel like you guys are
all
living the stories that you're telling
about the gsb by giving
your time back to us it's kind of a
testament to what
being a student or an alum at the gsp
actually looks like